4 c'est bonjour on en est à la quatrième
semaine du procès des attentats de
janvier 2015 qui sera entendu par la
justice ce jeudi et que doit-on attendre
de ces auditions
c'est une journée très intéressante qui
permet d'aller au fond des choses en
tout cas de comprendre le contexte qui a
donné naissance à ces nids de
radicalisation et ce bien avant les
attentats
alors on va aujourd'hui entendre des
mentors des frères kwasi aidé à midi
coulibaly et on va comprendre cette
quête et la filière des buttes chaumont
monde on va comprendre qu'ils étaient
ces prêcheurs qui ont effectué des
lavages de cerveau pour ces jeunes
hommes voient comprendre si qui les a
mis en relation avec des combattants en
irak ou en syrie des combattants
évidemment de l'état islamique également
d'al qaïda ce matin est donc entendue en
vidéo en première manche c'est un chef
de service de la dgs il est caché
derrière un paravent bien sûr il revient
sur la création de l'état islamique
ces moments de barbarie et la propagande
de 2,7 califat autoproclamé et puis il
donne donc des éléments sur le contexte
un des caricatures de mahomet il va
revenir sur la procédure de la filière
des buttes chaumont qui qui en relais
des candidats au djihad un homme ou
femme d'ailleurs
et puis il va également détaillé le
séjour en syrie d'hayat boumédiène
l'accompagnent dames et 10 coulibaly and
enquêteurs de la sous direction
antiterroriste sera entendue également
cet après-midi et puis comme vous le
disiez ensuite ce sera au tour des
mentors des frères coen chi donc à
commencer par le jet 10 peter chérif en
vidéoconférence depuis djibouti où il
est incarcéré puis farid benyettou le
fameux repenti que d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'avocats s'étonne de voir ici et
j'aimerais presque qu'ils soient
évidemment inculpé et puis un dernier
mentor des frères coen chi djamel beghal
lui aussi très controversé donc c'est
une journée qui va permettre de replacer
évidemment les attentats dans un
complexe géopolitique de la jeunesse
perdue et
mais de france jusqu'aux terres du
califat donc ce califat autoproclamé en
syrie et en irak
merci beaucoup katia technique pour
toutes ces précisions vous étiez en
direct de la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris